begin our search for a new justice of
the United States Supreme Court that
will begin immediately we have to pick
one that's going to be there for 40
years 45 years we need intellect we need
so many things to go you know there's so
many elements go into the making of a
great Justice of the Supreme Court you
got to hit every one of them well let's
talk about it with our panel because now
we know when this is allegedly going to
happen Steve Hays editor in chief for
the Weekly Standard Molly Hemingway
senior editor at the Federalist and
David Catanese senior politics writer
for US News and World Report privacy all
of you
all right so Steve today he says July
9th it's a week from Monday we know
because they've had this list for a long
time he's already interviewed some of
these folks but that's kind of like
rocket docket material to pick a justice
in a week and a half now I think they're
working back from the fall I mean Mitch
McConnell's made very clear that he
wants this done president Trump wants
this done by October justice seated by
October conceivably and I think it's a
priority Mitch McConnell's been planning
for this moment for years he's been
working with the White House for years
he's cleared much of the Senate
scheduled to address this and other
judicial vacancies we know that this is
Mitch McConnell's top priority it's
something that he's been looking at
doing going back before the election of
Donald Trump so I think Donald Trump is
is probably wise to move as quickly as
he's going to move and and whatever
Mitch McConnell can do to accelerate the
Senate schedule he ought to do that too
well not all senators are on board as we
know Senator Dianne Feinstein the
ranking member at the Democrat on the
Senate Judiciary Committee which is
going to have a lot to do with this
here's what she says about moving
forward as you sow so you reap
I think we will have a plan and it will
be announced by the Democratic leader at
an appropriate time but this is a very
serious situation and no one should
underestimate it
Somali of course Democrats are pushing
back saying well he said you can't ever
hold you know you have to fill the seat
in election year you have to hold it
open until after the election you can't
fill it you know Mitch McConnell told me
last night well we meant that in
presidential election year so she says
they've got a plan I don't know what
Democrats are planning to do Mitch
McConnell didn't just say that last
night he said that throughout 2016 and
the question wasn't whether every
election year is the same but whether
presidents should have the right to pick
their nominee so whether you think that
what Mitch McConnell did in 2016 was a
good idea or bad he was very clear and
explicitly clear and so were the people
who supported his plan that that was
about presidential election years
Democrats are in a really tough place
right now though there are Republicans
who might go squishy on a nominee from
Donald Trump but you have a lot of
Democrats who are running in states that
Donald Trump won overwhelmingly who will
have voters livid if they do not support
any qualified candidate that that Donald
Trump puts forth we think about the joe
Manchin's of the world and others David
that we're watching it's a very small
list but it could be enough to make a
difference one of the big issues that
was immediately jumped on by the left is
this idea of Rovi way Justice Kennedy
had been protective of abortion rights
that kind of thing and so we're you know
we're placing him you say it's a
Republican president replacing a
Republican nominee but it could be very
different in his case on these social
issues I want to play something that now
President Trump said during the debate
in October of 2016 with our Chris
Wallace when he was asked specifically
about whether or not he looked for
someone to overturn roe v wade or
whether that would happen but what I'm
asking you sir is do you want to see the
court overturn you just said you want to
see the court protect the Second
Amendment
do you want to see the court overturned
well if we put another two or perhaps
three justices on that's really what's
going to be has that's will happen and
that'll happen automatically in my
opinion because I am putting pro-life
and justices on the court
I will say this it will go back to the
states and the states will then make a
determination all right
so he actually said today I shouldn't
say that he was he was asked today at
the gaggle he said I'm not gonna ask
these potential nominees about Roe vs.
Wade because now he's getting on script
saying I shouldn't you know yeah you
don't want to be pinned down on that and
then had the nominee go in the hearing
and be asked but look this is gonna be
the Alamo for the left just the
statements coming out from the potential
2020 Democratic senators whether it be
Kamala Harris Kristin Gillibrand there's
a feeling among Democrats that although
Republicans had the power that Barack
Obama Democrats never fought hard enough
for Merrick garland and the left wants a
fight on this now the Republicans have
the votes and I think eventually
President Trump will get his nominee but
it is not gonna be without a hellfire
fight this fall from the left because
there they are I mean this is about roe
v-- wade this is about choice this is
about everything and I just think
there's gonna be a bigger fight than
then expected well whether or not you
are whether you're pro-choice or
pro-life it is widely regarded that Rho
V we roe v wade is just a really
horribly reasoned legal decision so the
question isn't really about whether you
support roe v wade or not even people
who are pro-choice recognize that it was
a poorly argued judicial decision but
the question but the question really
will be about your approach to the law
are you an originalist on questions of
the Constitution are you a textualist on
questions of the law you don't need to
ask about roe v wade because again so
many people regard it as just such a
horribly reason and we all know too that
these nominees when they get in front of
the Senate Judiciary Committee if it is
something really critical and difficult
they're gonna say I can't answer that
because that issue may be coming before
me so everybody's going to be combing
through every you know comma in their
record to see if they can find a clue
and what they would do and just watch
the two female senators Lisa Murkowski
from Alaska Susan Collins that's why
you're gonna see a lot of pressure on
them you see Democrats
additionaly them due to Republicans if
they could peel them away and say no I
mean their their handling of this
process is going to be very interesting
because I don't know where they go do
they decide to be that vote for a
justice that could potentially overturn
roe v wade there may be a lot of people
that think it's poorly word
but this is politics in there there's
gonna be a message from Democrats saying
this this core this new Trump Court with
two new Supreme Court justice will
overturn the right to abortion and at
least 30 states do you have to do is
find someone who's never written an
opinion on it or publicly answered a
question but but even that honestly even
that strikes me as optimistic I mean we
the the conversation here is for
sanguine about the possibility of a
fight over somebody's actual record and
the things that he or she has actually
written I don't think that's what's
gonna happen I think Democrats we've
seen already are so hysterical at the
prospect of a conservative court that
they're saying things that don't bear
any resemblance to the truth I mean you
have democratic or left-leaning analysts
making predictions about you know about
women's rights and where women are going
to be and what they'll have to do that
this is crazy
I think that's likely to be the tone
throughout this and the debate the real
debate is what are you inside the
Democratic Party and it's not
necessarily going to be about this
position itself it's all positioning I
think for 2020 well a lot of folks think
that whomever is nominated and confirmed
to the bench if it happens before the
midterms as is the plan it's only going
to drive up the resistance and the
Democrats to get out to the polls in the
midterms because they're not going to
want to be on the wrong side of this
again when it comes to them okay that's
it on this topic